hello there I'm John Oliver professional
swearword Sayer now on my show last week
tonight I try to provide the fairest
most accurate commentary possible
whether I'm covering the state of
America's deeply flawed prison system or
the state of Kansas is sex toy auction
but look sometimes I do go too far and
in the grand tradition of television
personalities who've made mistakes I
would like to offer a condescending
half-hearted apology that I don't really
mean now you may remember a while ago I
started a social media campaign to
tackle what I thought at the time was a
pressing issue I'm speaking of course of
my hashtag not my Christian movement now
it was it was designed to known enough
it was designed to protest the casting
of Jamie Dornan as Christian gray in the
upcoming Fifty Shades of Grey movie now
look I'm sorry if anyone was offended by
my incredibly accurate evaluation of the
casting choice for a movie whose target
audience going by the trailer seems to
be suburban mothers of three who have
somehow never had sex before my point my
point was not my point was not that the
sex in the Fifty Shades trailer was as
erotic as watching someone drop an
unpeeled carrot into a paper bag oh yeah
oh yeah it's a thing going into a
different thing oh yeah
that was not my point and my point was
also not that Jamie Dornan who I'm on
record as saying his hashtag not my
Christian is it is particularly wrong
for the part my real complaint is
Hollywood's unimaginative casting when
it came time to cast Christian Grey our
character described by fifty Shades or
thirty lambs as the epitome of male
beauty they found an actor who
specializes in handsome and I guess what
I'm driving at is it hurts not to have
even been asked because sure sure you
partially over for the epitome of male
beauty but whenever you need a Caucasian
foreigner or a cheerful weakling
suddenly my thought is blowing up and
that is why right now on YouTube in
front of all the world's teenagers and
they're fun ants I am going to record my
audition for the Fifty Shades of Grey
I'm recording my audition for a movie
that's already been made based on a book
I have never read so here goes let's do
this hello
I'm Christian Grey it pitted me of male
beauty according to Wikipedia I'm ready
to take a young woman on a journey from
frumpy nerd to fully realized sexual
being this is a thing that I Christian
Grey feel totally comfortable talking
about and doing maybe I'll tell her to
let her hair down and stop wearing paint
stained overalls all the time or or
maybe that's just the plot of 1990s teen
comedy she's all that either way I don't
know either way either way I'm presuming
this is all going to end in butt stuff
thank you thank you that's that's that's
it that's that's that's my
figured something got extremely hot in
here or extremely cold I don't know but
look in order to show how serious I am
I will now shackle myself to this chair
using Fifty Shades sex handcuffs I
bought at auction last week I will stay
at this desk until I've been cast in the
inevitable Fifty Shades of Grey sequel I
said I came to apologize so I will I'm
sorry Jamie Dornan you have made a
powerful enemy this day we'll be back in
February with new episodes of last week
tonight and who knows maybe I will still
be chained to this chair
goodbye goodbye there's not there's
nothing